the RGV sector our agents our chief are
only left with 31 drones to intercept
this now this type of event of unbalance
is unacceptable and the RGV that
continues to have high low illegal
immigration and high illegal drugs
crossing our border that being said
there's other high persistent
surveillance which includes aerostats
there were seven Arrow stats here in the
RGB sector and due to lack of funding
three have been
decommissioned and the remaining four
are going to be defunded by the end of
this year with that being said Chief
Ortiz what is a department currently
doing to assist with countering the
cartel technology and again 35
000 that we detected in the last year
thank you congresswoman good to see you
I will tell you that technology is uh
probably uh a priority or no definitely
is a priority for myself and
my leadership whether it's South Texas
or whether it's Arizona the suas issue
as you know cartels have Deep Pockets
they don't have to worry about policy I
have to worry about policy we have 201
small uas systems deployed throughout
the country and I intend to continue to
expand that at Great levels over the
next 24 months we have a counter uas
program as you might be familiar with
and we continue to expand that because
we recognize that the cartels have
become awfully sophisticated and a small
dirt no longer has to leave the the
Mexican side to smuggle a group of
migrants or narcotics across the border
he can do it virtually via a phone app
and a suas and so we need to continue to
expand that footprint but our policies
also have to match that we have to be
able to mitigate those 35
000 drone incursions that you just
described we are on the process and
we're in a process of mitigating a lot
of those uh criminal organizations and
being able to exploit where they're
coming from how they're doing it and
we're going to continue to expand that
as much as we can and then with respect
to the aerostats uh I'm a big fan of
aerostats when I was in Afghanistan and
I think uh some of the the committee
members will recall that aerostats kept
us safe and when I came down here in
2013 I was the architect of the aerostat
program here in South Texas and I could
when I went up to headquarters I
expanded it across multiple locations
across the Southwest border but it is an
expensive piece of technology and I have
to find an alternative for that now
Chief Ortiz can you tell the committee
and the members here in um that are in
the audience can you tell us how deep
into American soil have these cartel
drones actually come in
so it will vary some of the Drone
technology that the cartels are using
are very sophisticated and we've seen
incursions Miles Away from the immediate
border area for us we are doing I think
a a tremendous job of identifying where
these criminal organizations are
operating out of but we need to expand
that
with border patrol I have heard that
these drones from the cartels have come
up to eight miles into American land
would you say that is a is an accurate
statement
no ma'am how far uh do you do you
believe that they come into American
soil
I think it depends on terrain a lot of
areas along the Southwest border very
mountainous when you think about what we
have in Arizona and El Paso but then
when you think about what we're dealing
with here in South Texas and in some
areas in West Texas pretty flat country
so cartels can operate via line of sight
and once again it really depends on
their ability to leverage existing
systems whether it's cell phones and
whatnot
we just recently lost some of those
aerostat balloons in this past January
so what is the measure that the
department is using to fill the Gap
until we get to the next step
we currently have a team deployed in
looking at some alternatives to a
similar type of platform but that's less
expensive what we've seen in the past
with aerostats is it in these areas I'm
sorry I'm out of time I'm just going to
ask you how fast can we deploy some of
this technology we're hoping to deploy
it in the next six months man thank you
and I yield back the gentlelady yields I
want to thank our panel of witnesses for
their incredibly valuable testimony
today and uh Mr Kagan I want to
especially thank you you were a Democrat
invited witness and you showed up uh so
thank you for that uh the the folks who
invited you uh bailed on you but thank
you both for your service to our country
and for being here today and the members
of the committee they may have some
additional questions for you they'll
submit them in writing and it would be
great if you could get that back in
writing the Witnesses are dismissed and
our committee stands in recess for 15
minutes
hold on hold on
testing
hurry up
ladies and gentlemen we'll get started
here in just a couple of minutes if the
members could make their way to the
diocese
yes and so we got such a good chance
and we're waiting on Sheriff Coe and a
few other members or we got all the
members okay
guys find our other witness for us
thanks Ryan
while we're off the Record here and I
want to thank the media for being here
uh all of you that are back there with
your cameras I know sometimes people uh
criticize the media
but uh I just want to thank you for
being here today the story of what uh
what occurred in our our first round of
testimony needs to be told and I deeply
appreciate your presence here
thank you
Mr chairman
yeah go ahead while we're waiting I
would offer to write their headline for
them U.S border Patrol admits that there
is that we do not have operational
control of the Southern border that it
is out that it is um not secure
and that Biden Administration policy is
the cause
that's what he said
the Candor was astonishing it was
wouldn't it be nice if we could get that
from other Administration officials and
get it on a regular basis
we will go ahead and get started uh
the committee will come to order and I'm
pleased to welcome our second
uh panel of witnesses I ask that the
witnesses please rise and raise their
right hand
do you solemnly swear that the testimony
you give before the committee on
homeland security of the United States
House of Representatives will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you guide
let the record reflect that the
witnesses have answered in the
affirmative thank you
I would now like to formally introduce
our second panel of witnesses
Stephen McGraw has served as the
Director and and Colonel of the Texas
Department of Public Safety since 2009.
he served in both Texas and federal law
enforcement since 1977.
in various capacities across our entire
country as Frontline leader for a state
that is among the most affected by the
crisis at our Southern border
Mr McGraw's insights and expertise are
invaluable
Bradco is Sheriff of Kinney County Texas
a border County that has faced the very
real life effects of this crisis
Sheriff Coe has first-hand experience in
encountering illegal aliens and
protecting his community we thank the
sheriff for making the drive over and
look forward to hearing what he has to
say today
and Chris Cabrera is the vice president
of the national border patrol Council a
labor union representing the border
patrol agents and support Personnel Mr
Cabrera is an army veteran so that makes
us Brothers
and a current CBP agent so he has
first-hand knowledge of the scope of the
threat before us here as well as
understanding of what our brave Board of
personnel have to endure every day I
thank the witnesses for being here and
the witness's full statements will
appear in the record I now recognize Mr
McGraw to kick us off for five minutes
to summarize his opening statement
you're recognized
could you turn it'll it'll turn green
yes sir
I was trying to delay the time clock
I'll do anything to get a little more
time but uh chairman this 11th time is
the record department plug said they've
testified before Congressional hearings
and this is a very important issue has
been continues to be and I can tell you
the most significant Public Safety
homeland security threat to the state
and the nation for that matter is an
unsecured international border with
Mexico
it's been that way for some time and
this the border states everyone's a
border state Alabama everyone in here is
a part of a border SEC New York near
border state in that regard simply
because we've failed to secure the
international border with Mexico what's
happened over the years as we've allowed
the Mexican cartels to metastasize to
something much larger than they've ever
been the most powerful ruthless
a depraved and violent criminal
organizations of the world and they're
on our doorstep they've got command and
control elements six of those cartels
operate throughout Texas they've
dominated
the lucrative drug and human smuggling
Market
cocaine heroin methamphetamine Whoever
thought methamphetamine 10 years ago you
wouldn't imagine it but they own it
right now the same thing with fentanyl
they've taken that over as well I know
you've talked a little bit about that
already in terms of the threat as it
stands so there's no question about it
it's an unscared border is a problem
it's not just a federal problem it
becomes a local problem with the sheriff
next to me I do have to put this in I
got to commend certainly Chief Raul
Ortiz I've worked with for for over a
decade outstanding professional and he
oversees a highly professional Elite
organization of men and women that serve
on the front line of our homeland
security and National Security defense
the U.S border Patrol we're very proud
to work with them Texas is a very Pro
law enforcement state pro-military state
pro-law and Order State and supports
their border patrol to the point where
two years ago when the governor I
visited he was upset that all of a
sudden we've seen what we saw in 2014.
2014 we had three hundred thousand you
heard Chief Ortiz talking about 300 000
other company children and family units
it's swarmed and swapped and overwhelmed
the U.S border Patrol
and since then the governor that is
preparing for a mass migration event if
it happens again because what happens it
takes border patrol off the line
so what what do we have in 2021
and we we were planning for failed State
scenario catastrophic event scenario but
instead what we got what we got is a
federal policy disaster okay that
incentivized illegal migrations that are
criminalized illegal migration
so it's not a matter of just in terms of
consequences if you're actually
rewarding people and this is the
greatest country in the world and if
you're going to reward them
and telling me come here and we're going
to give you a notice to disappear that's
what they're going to do they're going
to continue to come in droves and the
cartels have exploited it they use
social media okay they use information
Warfare they use all the military
applications in terms of whether it's
Logistics but command and control
information operations intelligence and
certainly the the uh the demonstration
or use of or application of lethal Force
and when we talk about semantics in
terms of terrorism the governor
designated the cartels as terrorist
organizations because in effect that's
what they are I mean how many Americans
have they killed versus Al Qaeda and
Isis and Sunni extremist groups and they
do it daily and the most most recent
threat that was really disturbing from
Texas because they cartel's always been
making money now they get to read
billions of money billions of dollars of
money just from the human trafficking
side they extort both on both sides of
the border and not to mention okay the
Mexican cartels are collaborating with
our gangs these Regional gangs these
space-based gangs these transnational
gangs to support the criminal activities
on both sides of the border so it only
makes it worse okay and not just a
border issue it becomes a Statewide
issue it affects every community in the
state as it relates to fentanyl is that
it's not enough to make money from a
poly drug cocktail which they were doing
now because it's much more profitable
you know how about selling to our kids
or Youth and anybody you know
look-alikes of Oxycodone Oxycontin
Adderall okay Percocet and almost
identical you can't tell the difference
our scientists can't tell the difference
in your own DEA administrator nurses at
six out of ten of those pills have a
lethal dose of fentanyl of two
milligrams that's a concern and yes we
have seen deaths and they don't really
care yeah you'd think that they would
but they'd rather they can expand
profits just in terms by increasing
Addiction in that regard so now they
they're not just in terms of the
overdose death it's poisonous because
it's a substitute
so you know what's a state to do and uh
underground under Governor Greg Abbott
he lost operation Lone Star over two
years ago and deployed thousands of
National Guard
the Troopers the special agents that
work for DPS and certainly our Texas
Rangers our tactical teams aircraft you
know tactical Marine unit and the impact
is always you know felt first and
foremost at the local level well the
sheriff and our local police departments
in that regard and found resources and
worked with the legislature to get
billions of dollars of Texas funeral
dollars have been invested in doing
everything we can to to help border
patrol perform their vitally important
mission
detect interdict transitional criminal
activity between the ports of Entry I
think that's my time so
I'll be quiet now Mr chairman
well thank you and I didn't I should
have asked this at the beginning do you
prefer to be called director or Colonel
um but uh thank you for your those are
two nice terms have been called much
worse well thanks for your opening
statement I'd like I'd now like to
recognize Sheriff Co for five minutes to
summarize his opening statement thank
you all for being here today like I said
my name is Brad Koh I'm the sheriff of
Kinney County Texas
I'm currently in my second term prior to
this I spent 30 years with U.S border
patrol all of which I spent my time in
Kenny County
Kinney county has 16 miles of riverfront
property with Mexico
and we are the 27th largest county in
the state but population wise we only
have 3 200 people
I have six full-time deputies and eight
part-time deputies to cover the
1300 square miles which most of our time
is spent close to town leaving very
little coverage for the rest of the
county
currently we're under siege by Olivia
islands and Smugglers coming through the
county trying to get to destinations
within the United States
with the current open door policy Kinney
county has seen a dramatic increase in
illegal alien activity
the number of migrants seen on game
cameras
that I currently have deployed
throughout the state thanks to DPS we're
averaging between 160 and 180 people per
night that are going through the county
unchallenged
that comes out to roughly 60 000 people
entered through my County this year
these are also considered god-wise by
Kenny County because we don't have the
resources to go out and track and try to
apprehend these people walking through
the county
uh the damaged offenses water lines and
structures has ranchers spending more
than they can afford to keep their
properties up and running
the loss of the ability to grow crops is
also a huge issue large groups of people
walking through the property creating
Trails kills the grass that the
livestock the Sheep the goats and the
cattle depend on for survival
our game ranches we have exotic game
ranches where you can hunt animals year
round and some of these out of these
hunts will cost you anywhere between 40
on the high end on the 40 to 80 thousand
dollars per animal
with the number of illegal aliens
walking through the county it's making
it more and more difficult for the
hunters to be successful paying these
large fees to get the animal of their
choice if we lose them I lose the county
on the smuggling aspect
we have six count we have six roads that
lead directly away from the border and
two others that circumvent the Border
Pro checkpoint in Uvalde County just
east of us
these highways have seen an
unprecedented increase in human
smuggling activity
for calendar year 2022 which was last
year Canyon County deputies after he
handed 741 human Smugglers
and we filed over 3 000 felony cases
against these Smugglers
it's a huge increase from calendar year
2021 when we apprehended 169 human
sponsors
we are currently on track right now to
exceed 900 Smugglers for the year
in February alone the shortest month of
the year we did 95 Smugglers
with the increase in human human
smuggling
increase the chances of vehicle Pursuits
and bailouts
the number of Pursuits to increase with
you with the human smuggling
apprehensions
these increases risk traffic
the risk of traffic accidents death and
damages to property
with the increase in Pursuits that
result in traffic accidents puts a huge
strain on our community resources
kidney County only has one EMS crew on
duty at any given time
our First Responders or for the fire
department are all to volunteer
we had an accident earlier in the in the
year where I actually was in December
it was a Pursuit the vehicle tried to
avoid this being spiked lost control of
the vehicle killed three including the
driver plus three others critically
injured
we had to borrow resources from another
County
to handle that situation
our EMS Crews were completely tied up
which took them away from their regular
duties of servicing the county
uh all right in our placing our
volunteers for the fire department
they were all on scene they had to leave
their jobs to come handle help with that
accident
because it was rolled over because
people were rejected and killed we had
to call in air support we had to call in
air life from San Antonio and San Angelo
in the event they were going to be
needed
which brings up the question who's
paying for this my County doesn't have
the resources to pay for air life
as soon as the airline's helicopter hits
the ground it's roughly forty five
thousand dollars
we don't have that kind of money the
people that they're hauling they're
transporting to from the hospitals don't
have that kind of money they don't have
the insurance
we had an incident last year
we had a rollover
EMS shows up our only crew shows up
they're about 20 miles south of town one
of our locals in town suffers a heart
attack
he didn't make it
would he have made it had EMS been able
to get to him in time that's one of the
questions we will never know
and that is all I have well one other
thing
I have to fight tooth and toenail to get
what I have to protect my ranchers
that's all we have we had a movie
industry Lonesome Dove the Alamo on and
on and on about 150 movies were made in
Kenny County during the lifespan of
Alamo Village
that has gone away the sheep and sheep
and goat industry we reigned Supreme in
the world with our sheep and goat
industry that has gone away all we have
now is our Hunters
that's all we have to protect
accountants to support the county we
have one grocery store one gas station
and 3 200 people
if I lose any of that I lose the whole
kennel and I will go to my grave
fighting for this to keep my County as
safe as I can
thank you
thank you Sheriff I really appreciate
your testimony I now recognize Mr
Cabrera for five minutes to summarize
his opening statement
good morning chairman Greene thank you
for providing me the opportunity to
testify on behalf of the national border
patrol Council
the mbpc represents 16 000 front line
agents of the border patrol my name is
Chris codetta I joined the border patrol
in 2001 after serving four years in the
U.S army as a paratrooper I spent my
entire border patrol career here in the
Rio Grande Valley sector of Texas
in fiscal year 2022 the border patrol
made an unprecedented 2.2 million
apprehensions this figure is
approximately five times the number of
apprehensions made in the last year of
the Trump Administration it's a clear
sign of how the Border policies of this
Administration are failing approximately
half of the individuals we arrested last
year were expelled under title 42. as
you know this Authority will cease after
May of this year
and what happened to the other million
that were not expelled the vast majority
were released into this country under
either a notice or two appear or paroled
in addition to apprehensions we made
there were well over 1.2 million
confirmed illegal immigrants that evaded
capture in the last two years they got
away simply because we didn't have
enough manpower to apprehend him
to put this in perspective the Rio
Grande Valley is approximately 1.3
million people in the population
we had almost the entire population of
this region Escape just walk right into
this country last year
if this isn't the definition of a
problem I don't know what is
if we're going to address this chaos in
the Border we need two things first and
foremost we must end Catch and Release
Winston Churchill once famously said
that Americans always do the right thing
only after they have tried everything
else when it comes to catch and release
I believe that Winston Churchill was
right first time I testified before
Congress was before the Senate Homeland
Security in 2015. I told the Senate then
and I will tell you today as long as we
continue to release illegal immigrants
into this country they will continue to
come it's that simple
ending Catch and Release not only makes
com not only makes common sense it's the
law section 235b of the immigration and
nationality react act requires Homeland
Security to detain all migrants
apprehended insulin entering illegally
Homeland Security May and I emphasize
May parole individuals on a case-by-case
basis for humanitarian reasons or
significant public benefit that's not
what the Biden Administration has been
doing this past two years a federal
judge just vacated the administration's
parole policy which is a Catch and
Release by a different name
the second issue is congress's
responsibility you need to Resource the
border patrol to accomplish our mission
of securing this border border patrol
Staffing hovers around 19 300 agents the
Tucson sector Chief just recently
testified before house oversight
committee that the border patrol needs
22 000 agents to deal with this current
crisis
increasing our net Manpower by 2 700
agents is going to take tremendous
effort that will require us to do two
things simultaneously first we need to
keep the agencies we already have and we
need to recruit more agents it sounds
like a simple problem our border patrol
attrition rate is 6.9 percent which is
72 percent higher than the office of
field operations
the bad news is that our attrition rate
is expected to climb over nine percent
by 2028. the primary reason we cannot
retain and recruit agents is a lack of
pay parity with other federal law
enforcement agencies we have I have
spent most of my life protecting this
country whether it be for the Army or
the 20 years 21 years I've suspent in
the Border Patrol
I've told my wife that you don't join
the service to get rich however if I
were to leave for another agency I'd
probably make about fifteen thousand
dollars more for many agents with young
families that come from different parts
of the country it's a no-brainer for
them so they leave as soon as they get
here
um it's simple for them if we continue
to Hemorrhage personnel
there's no way we're going to secure
this border we spent billions on
aircraft on technology on fencing and
that's great we we appreciate
all of that stuff that you guys have
given us however we have not
sufficiently invested in our agents
which is the most important element in
border security
last Congress Senators Portman Cinema
and Langford introduced s4775 which has
a provision section four to address our
Recruitment and Retention issues
I know the committee is working on
comprehensive legislation to address
this crisis I appreciate your effort and
the fact that you came all the way down
here to have this hearing that we need
now that you know what we need I
respectfully ask that you take action
and that action must include addressing
our retention and recruitment issues
thank you for the opportunity to testify
and I will gladly answer any questions
you may have
the gentleman uh I want to thank all
three of you for being here I really
appreciate it
I want to ask the members
that they'll be recognized or tell the
member members they'll be recognized in
order of seniority as typical for our
committee for questioning if there is
time for an additional round we may
allow that to happen
and again we'll be recognized in order
of seniority I now recognize myself for
for my five minutes questioning
uh Mr Cabrera and and is that Cabrera or
I want to make sure I'm pronouncing your
name cabreras okay
um
could you briefly talk about how the
border patrol agents have been affected
by the border crisis physically and
mentally
you know um physically it's it's been a
rough patch for us these last few years
we lost many agents to uh to covet we
lost quite a few to covid we've had a
couple officer involved deaths with uh
uh just recently uh in December we lost
an agent uh to a vehicle accident
um on top of that suicides uh border
patrol I think lost 17 people in the
last year put that in perspective NYPD
has 35
000 officers I believe more or less and
they lost four so it is a big issue we
see a lot of stuff out there that the
average person doesn't see I think that
what hits most people folks the hardest
is
what happens with the children we see we
see a lot of young kids coming across
three four five years old seven years
old that are unaccompanied their parents
are already here in the United States
and they they send them by themselves
and who knows about the uh hundreds if
not thousands more that that never make
it through so that that I think is more
on the mental aspect of it uh as well as
some of the physical
um
it's a difficult job it's increasingly
getting harder by the fact that we're
not
put in a position to do the job that
that we were trained to do I mean we're
I think the border patrol is
the only
Union you're ever going to see in the
history of unions that is actually
asking for more work where we're just
just let us work let us do our job we
don't care where you put the coffee pot
we don't care about lumbar supports for
our chairs we just want to go to work
um and and we're just asking that you
let us work
well I really appreciate that
um
let me ask uh let me ask this question
of you as well sir what do your agents
share with you what are their thoughts
about the policy changes that occurred
uh you know in in 21. oh the morale is
down the morale is down significantly um
if you look at our numbers now uh versus
our numbers two years ago you'll see
that that the numbers are lopsided most
of our agents are are frustrated with
the job they're frustrated with the fact
that we're we're babysitters um
maybe 30 to 40 percent of our agents
actually get out to the field on any
given day and then a lot of times they
get called back in to process or
transport somebody so the uh the real
bad guys the Smugglers the ones that are
harming people the people that are
bringing in drugs into this country or
trafficking and in humans or kids
they're getting away and and that
affects the agents in their their desire
to do their job and you know let's face
it if you have a young kid say that
comes from Charlotte North Carolina and
he joins the border patrol and his wife
comes down say they go to Big Bend and
it's two and a half hours to get to a
Walmart much less a hospital the wife
can't find a job because she can't speak
Spanish and then ice comes around and
says hey we'll give you more pay Monday
through Friday weekends and holidays off
and we'll get you back home of course
they're going to jump ship so we're not
only losing seasoned agents we're losing
brand new agents so there's no way we're
going to catch up with that
let me ask uh director McGraw a quick
question how much is uh DPS spending per
month for border security and how much
was DPS spending before January 21. the
state legislature and the government
have invested a lot of money over the
years and certainly 800 800 million
dollars in the Department of Public
Safety alone
but when we saw the record numbers and I
say doctor numbers 1.3 million
apprehensions in Texas in 2021 and again
1.4 million in 2023. the governor
legislature has dedicated billions of
dollars now so when we do these
intensified operations and we continue
to send troops down and conduct these
around-the-clock operations so that
there are threefold of what they were
before
importantly now we have the National
Guard and the state's paying for that
National Guard a very important part of
it because as border patrol and probably
Chief warranties already talked about
you know Personnel you've got to have
technology you got to have
infrastructure and they also need
doctrine right the correct Doctrine and
policies in place to be able to secure
the border and uh and one last thing I'd
like to at least put a pitch in for for
border patrol the federal government's
always undervalued the patrol function
they always have and and don't recognize
the post 911 environment that Patrol
function how important it is in terms of
prevention and certainly they do need to
be be on par with their other Federal
counterparts we need more Boots On the
Border less wing tips and then you get
right down to it and that's really what
you know border patrol brings us
I got your reference thank you just to
summarize that it was your budget has
had to go up three times if I understood
you correctly not counting the National
Guard's additional costs at the border
at least threefold exactly that's it all
right thank you my time is up I now
recognize chairman Higgins
Colonel McCraw that's true
what's a relationship like between DPS
and DHS right now how is it been
impacted by the policies of the new
Administration
and we don't have the policies of an
Administration impact our relationships
with our partners bottom line it's a too
few many law enforcement officers in
Texas you know 70 000 you know local and
state and so we work well with our
federal Partners we integrated
operations it's Texas we get along with
each other we like each other we respond
and we got each other's back so it
hasn't changed it hasn't counted answer
I would expect from a law enforcement
professional because you're referring to
your relationships with the with the men
and women you work with on a regular
basis to perform your mission to the
best of your ability
the the current Administration as ever
executive Administration in the United
States has a constitutional
responsibility to secure the
international borders
to help our sovereign states maintain
operational control
with the Mexican border is is absolutely
a constitutional requirement do you feel
that that this Administration compared
to the last Administration is fulfilling
that obligation we'll have absolutely
not obviously we're testified or in my
written statement is that we've
incentivized you know a global Mass
migration event and that deliberately
impacts on Border Patrol and law
enforcement in our communities across
the border so clearly it's had a
negative impact and there's consequences
there's an unsecured international
border would you I agree Colonel would
you concur that that ultimately the
responsibility for that failed policy uh
is upon the shoulders of secretary
mayorkas and President Biden I'd say
it's certainly Administration who
exactly who it doesn't really matter
it's a failed policy and it's a federal
responsibility to do it and it's not
being done period
well I would say that it falls upon a
shoulders as secretary mayorkus as the
executive that allegedly has the has the
background and the knowledge to perform
according to the to the instructions of
the president of the United States he
also has a responsibility to advise the
president if if the president's policies
are failing in in the mission and and
actually bringing injury upon the nation
so I would say the failure of of our of
our policies as we see them at our
Southern border fall squarely upon the
shoulders secretary mayorcus Sheriff Co
my 1911 brother thank you for being here
no thank you um let's talk about what
happens to these these illegals when
they get into the country and into your
county
uh
you you come across these guys you have
to take them into custody in some way
what happens after you have concluded
your law enforcement interaction with
them uh what's the responsiveness of ice
under this Administration versus the
last well if if my deputies come across
from say on somebody's property we filed
charges on them for criminal trust backs
uh DPS and the governor was very
gracious giving us a two and a half
million dollar Grant or to uh assist
with the prosecution and hire people so
that we can get this done uh same thing
if we catch a human Smuggler we file
charges on them on everything that we
can stack on them and it's been very
successful one of the issues we do have
working with ice and some border patrol
is border patrol will catch them and the
landowner is present when they're caught
and the landowner will say I want these
turned over to the county to the
Sheriff's office so I can file criminal
charges against them border patrol
refuses
if we have uh if we catch an illegal
alien and for whatever reason we cannot
prosecute them because of it because we
don't have bench space for a female or
they're underage whatever the case may
be we have problems having ice to come
pick them up they say no it doesn't meet
our quality our status so we need to
kick them down so the sheriff to stay
charges if if you're able to prosecute
on the state charges for say Criminal
Trespass you you conclude that
adjudication at some point they're still
illegal within the country it has the
federal government puts you in a
position to illegally release aliens
within the country several times I've
tried uh we'll give you an example we
had an accident there were three that
were had very minor injuries they
refused to go to the hospital EMS
cleared them
I called border patrol to come pick them
up they said no because they've been in
an accident we will not take them ice
refused to take them they wanted me to
kick them down the road
took it upon myself we took them back to
the international border we took them to
the Port of Entry and sent them home
that's for a good Sheriff would do
thank you for your testimony gentlemen
Mr chairman I yield gentlemen yields I
now recognize Vice chair guest
uh thank you Mr chairman uh Karma crawl
um first of all I want to thank you I
want to thank Governor Abbott the men
and women under your control for the
billions of dollars uh that the state of
Texas has invested in fighting this
crisis uh and I see that that investment
has been successful uh in some aspects
uh in your written testimony I'll say
that during the two-year activity of
operation Lone Star you report that
there's been more than 350 million
dosage units of fentanyl that have been
seized 19 tons of methamphetamine and
that you and the men and women of the
Texas National Guard the game wardens
the DPS officials have helped apprehend
and turn over to border patrol over 350
000 illegal immigrants uh in your
statement there are some very compelling
parts
and the second paragraph particularly
where you say that the Texas Department
of Public Safety that is your assessment
that the most significant Public Safety
and homeland security threat to Texas
and the nation is our unsecured
international border with Texas
uh you go on to say the federal
government has failed to do its
constitutional Duty and secure the
border that this failure comes at the
detriment of our citizens
and the benefit of the Mexican drug
cartels
uh Colonel would you agree with the
statement that border security is
National Security absolutely
you go on to describe our Mexican border
as porous
and then finally at the end of page one
of your written statement you say that
there is compelling evidence that the
federal government has incentivized
rather than criminalized illegal
immigration
and then you set four specific figures
as number of immigrants who have been
apprehended just within the state of
Texas not with On the Border as a whole
2021 you talk about 1.3 million
immigrants being apprehended just within
the state of Texas 2022 we see that
number grew to 1.4 million and your
testimony goes on to make sure that we
know that that does not include the
number of gotaways which would
significantly inflate those figures
we know that in May of this year the
Administration has indicated that they
will end title 42.
which this Administration has said in
December uh that we could see across the
southern border a number up to 14 000
immigrants a day coming across the
southern border uh my question to you
Colonel is uh in your opinion uh based
on the information that you have uh once
title 42 expires what impact will that
have on the number of immigrants that
you're seeing coming into the state of
Texas on a daily basis a little certain
increase how much it's difficult to
project
but there's no doubt that anything that
incentivizes or encourages or something
that the cartels can exploit from an
information standpoint they're going to
encourage more to come
and the more that comes and the less
border patrol is able to do their job
and the more difficult it is for the
state to Middle step in and help them do
their job and what information have you
received from DHS as to their plan of
action as to how they plan to address
this coming surge of immigrants when
title 42 expires well we work with our
local border patrol sectors so there's a
state plan whether it's a federal plan
or not we can't tell but we certainly
don't have a state plan that then brings
together all law enforcement in Texas
and the National Guard and integrated
waiting in terms of response if it gets
if it as it continues to get worse but
right now it's never been worse at 1.4
million this is a historic High you've
got to go back to 1986 to see these
types of numbers in Texas and we track
it by calendar year
again across the entire Southern border
over 250 000 immigrant seized in a
single month uh uh if title 42 goes away
if the predictions that this
Administration have has in place uh
those numbers will far exceed the worst
month in the history of immigration and
so I guess my question is is there
currently a plan in place that you're
aware of
by DHS as to how they intend to handle
the serves have they briefed your agency
because clearly you're providing uh
support capacity uh to our Frontline CBP
officers uh and so here we are roughly
two months away 60 days away from uh
title 42 going away uh is there a plan
in place uh have they briefed you in
your department on what you can do to
prepare for the coming serves and uh
you'll back after the answer to that
question yeah there is a plan in place
because the state of Texas doesn't need
the federal government's permission to
protect it the government's made it
clear that we're going to have a plan in
place we have a plan in place it's
integrated across all three levels of
government and it's multi-jurisdictional
multi-disciplinary I can tell you that
thank you uh sir the gentleman yields
and I now recognize the gentleman from
North Carolina Mr Bishop thank you Mr
chairman gentlemen uh this hearing has
already been extraordinarily significant
because the U.S border Patrol Chief
testified to Congress that the
administration's policy of releasing
illegals in the United States as opposed
to detaining them and removing them
is the cause and the driver of the
crisis at the border which he
characterizes being out of control and
not subject to operational control of
the United States government
so that's a big deal
and uh and now I'm curious in this stage
Colonel McCraw you said something that
sort of got me back on something that
that sort of is something I've focused
on a lot or thought about a lot and I
kind of I don't know what your answers
are going to be they may be adverse to
me politically but I'd be fine
um because I I think about you know
we've got so we've seen we all focus on
the circumstances as they are and
they're very bad and they're in all the
bad effects that we're seeing in terms
of uh uh members of the border patrol
Patrol Patrol Mr cabareta and their
families and uh Sheriff what you're
seeing and Chase is in your in your
community uh Colonel what you're trying
to do in terms of the investment your
state has to make to get this under
control but here's what I wonder about
is where could we go if this continues
as it is for another two years we're
only halfway into this through this
Administration they're devoted to this
policy that's so destructive so where
could we end up later on and I'm always
my mind always goes back you with the
phrase that you use Colonel you were
talking about uh these the cartels the
trans uh National criminal organizations
and you mentioned command and control I
heard earlier that 35 000 flights that
congresswoman De La Cruz uh point out of
those drone flights they're coming
across I made some people sort of smile
not knowingly when I asked and hearing a
year or so ago why we don't shoot them
down and they also like you can't do
that so we're having you know they're
bringing drugs and people over with the
use of farm better equipment than border
patrol has available
uh I always get the name of the town
wrong I think it's Cooley a con in
January had not the first but the mo the
latest war between the Mexican military
and the Sinaloa cartel over the arrest
of uh uh ovidio Guzman son of El Chapo
and I would love to show you these
pictures I don't have but Los Angeles
time has sometimes has some great
pictures that show flaming tractor
trailers and uh and smash cars and some
one or two of the Narco tanks the with
these improvised rigs on him that cartel
member cartel Fighters taking on the
Army firing 50 caliber weapons at uh
aircraft in the air
and the thing and I understand where
it's a whole different deal in the
United States but if you have I'm told
Mr Cabernet that uh border patrol always
tells me that nothing comes across the
border unless the cartel permits it and
I understand is that basically true sir
oh yes sir that's true and I hear that
the 15 billion dollars of income comes
to the cartel
uh just from the fees to for people to
come abroad come across and a lot of
them owe those fees we're hearing about
those stories and they're and I heard uh
HSI or uh I forget what it is uh which
agency but is is seeing a surge in
violence relating to collecting those
fees so you have hundreds of thousands
or millions of people coming in
obviously very most of them perfectly
fine people and they want to abide by
the law but they're all under the thumb
of a cartel that's growing across the
border and you talked about the command
and control the capabilities they have
Colonel what's to prevent them from
developing in the United States the
circumstance that you saw in Korea kind
where they could go to war against
American American law enforcement
military uh facility uh forces well
first of all the Mexican cartels are
already inside the United States they
have command and control elements in
here involved and to support their
operations of drug and human trafficking
they were and they work with the gangs
that we talked about before where you
see most of the violence okay manifest
itself as relates to the cartel is with
ganks and through gangs if you talk to
local law enforcement you'll anybody
will tell you even in the fentanyl Mart
it doesn't matter what Market it is it's
the gangs and their collaboration with
each other and with the cartels are the
biggest problem right now uh the Mexican
cartels own Mexico it's a bottom line
through intimidation hyper violence
coercion and and frankly corruption if
our policy continues to profit them and
build them and build the sort of the
people they can abuse and manipulate for
their own purposes couldn't they
strengthen in the United States to the
point that they're that kind of a hazard
well seemingly compassionate policy of
allowing everybody in the world to come
to the United States is anything but if
you turn them over as you noted to the
Mexican cartels and there's too many
rapes there's too many violent crimes
that are committed upon those women and
children that are moved into this
country and the extortion continues not
just in terms when they get to the river
they got the money they'll continue it
on in stash houses in some cases Chinese
in particular we've come across in terms
of whether indentured servitude they
don't have 50 70 thousand dollars to pay
to get here they owe a criminal
organization that money okay to be able
to to work off their debt and whether
it's the sex trafficking industry we've
seen when young girls and women have
been attracted from and recruited from
Central America and from in central
Mexico on the promise of a domestic
servant I mean these are brutal depraved
you know cowardly criminals that can
care less and uh and certainly they they
impact in our profession it's the
absence of crime and disorder that
defines success and right now there's
anything but the absence of crime and
disorders relates to the border and it
impacts every community in the nation at
risk the chairman will gavel me down I'd
like Mr Cabrera to answer that question
too do you see any risk of the kind of
Specter that I described
in the United States
as far as that happening I mean we we
have had issues here in the in the Rio
Grande Valley
um I know that there's cartel members
living among us in our area not just in
our area and probably everyone's area
that are just flying under the radar
um there's always a possibility whether
it's on a small scale I can't see the
larger scale taking off just for the
fact that
our law enforcement is not corrupt like
they it is in on the Mexican side but
there there will be violence on it yeah
thank God for y'all Mr chairman I'm
sorry thank you uh the gentleman is uh
humored and uh now yields uh the next uh
I'd like to recognize our next uh member
uh from Florida Mr Jimenez
thank you uh Mr chairman Mr chairman I I
heard a story uh Monday
um
when I was in Miami about a an
individual to try to cross and was
captured by the cartel and and thinking
that everybody in Miami has money they
called his cousin and FaceTime the
cousin didn't have the money and they
murdered his basically murdered his
cousin on FaceTime because he didn't he
couldn't give up the ten thousand
dollars uh that that's the kind of
people that uh that we're dealing with
have absolutely no no value for human
life it's all about profit so
uh
have you told the the has the by
Administration gotten the word of what
it is they need to do in order to to fix
the problem at the at the border it'd be
even a lot of smart people back there'd
be possible not to know what's the right
thing to do this is not rocket science I
I agree and so do you think that the do
you think do you think the president of
the United States is dumb
I'm not going to comment on that do you
think do you think that I don't even see
it do you think the Secretary of do you
think that the Secretary of Homeland
Security is dumb certainly he's not okay
so the only thing you can come up with
is this is done on purpose
there's no I can't see it otherwise it's
done on purpose I don't know that it's
meant to be malevolent and to erotic the
problems it has but it certainly has
well you'd have to be pretty dumb not to
see that what you're doing is is
malevolent and it's actually has real
dire consequences in the United States
so it's actually done on purpose
I've come to that conclusion a long time
ago they're actually doing this on
purpose right whatever the reason why I
don't know yeah whatever the reasons you
know because this is not a political
issue it's a public safety issue and it
hurts I got it so now okay now that we
we know that it's on purpose okay now
let's move on to something else okay all
right how many different cartels are
there on the southern border well in
Texas which we focus on there's six
Mexican cartels that operate
how many do you have any Intelligence on
how many members how many are members of
the co I mean how many members of the
cartels have on the border on the
southern on on the Mexican side no you
don't no we've got good we've got some
estimations in terms of working with DEA
along those lines but exact numbers no
not exactly what's your estimation I I
wouldn't want to because the extensions
of the cartels I mean I wouldn't want
even to project in terms of how many
members but clearly there's as many
members of the cartel than there are in
gangs in Texas and we've identified over
a hundred thousand gang members so it's
it's so it's going to be 100
000. you think at least a hundred
thousand there's gonna be because at
some point and whether they're directly
or indirectly cartel members there's no
question they've got an army of people
down there in fact I mean we know from
past experience does that is the whole
part we're former Mexican military that
went over to be the enforcement off of
arm of the cartel the golf cartel moved
over created its own cartel so you have
you know this continuing you know
rebranding and and splitting of cartels
and they continue to as we've talked
about before so metastasized does the
Mexican does the Mexican military have
the capacity to deal with these cartels
I don't they haven't demonstrated the
capacity to deal with the cartels but do
you think they have the capacity no I
don't know okay because it takes the
capacity includes will well that's my
next bottom line you beat me to the
punch because then do you think they
have the will well I know the government
of Mexico does not have the will thank
you I do too I think the governor of
Mexico does not have the will
um they may have the will if the drugs
that are poisoning us we're actually
poisoning the Mexican people
so I I really have started to have some
doubts about where this government of
Mexico lies and is there a a deal a
secret Alliance something that says hey
keep the drugs out of Mexico okay and
I'll leave you alone you can go ahead
and poison the Americans all you want
there's no there's no news to the fact
that that Mexico has had issues with
corruption as it relates to the Mexican
cartels
and and yet the policies of the Biden
Administration actually helps the
cartels because they're they're making
huge profits off of off of immigration
right so the incentive policies actually
are helping them the cartels grow in
power and their ability to kill
Americans and yet the abiding
Administration knows they're wrong and
continues to do it yeah there's clearly
there was an at the end of the day the
impact on the cartels is they're richer
and more powerful than they were before
this Mass migration began all right and
that is all due to the failed policies
or the Biden Administration which which
we have to assume they know
are wrong
I'm not going to say what they assume I
just know that it's not rocket science
to figure this out yeah or brain surgery
actually I mean you know we have a
physician I think brain surgery is a
little complicated but yes okay yes sir
I got it okay thank you yeah I yield
back
thank uh thank you
um and I recognize our next witness or
our next uh questioner the gentleman
from Texas Mr fluger thank you chairman
uh I think all of you for being here for
your service uh to protect this country
and keep it safe
we have had what I think what I would
characterize as a groundbreaking
testimony today by Chief Ortiz
chief of the Border Patrol and he said
that he does not believe we have
operational control over the southern
border number two he does not believe
that at least five of the nine sectors
on along the Southwest border that it is
secure and that we have a policy crisis
uh and Mr Cabrera
um you know I'd like you to speak on
behalf how many uh people do you
represent in the National border patrol
Council 16 500. please speak on behalf
of 16 500.
do you believe do they believe that we
have operational control of our Southern
border that it is secure absolutely not
um you know we've heard a lot today uh I
appreciate your testimony about the
morale do you feel again speaking on
behalf of those 16 500 do they feel
supported by the commander-in-chief by
secretary mayorkas do they feel like
they have the resources they need to do
their job absolutely not
how sad is that uh that that you have
testified that we have not sufficiently
invested in our agents
um we're we hear you we support you
how sad is it do you want a bipartisan
solution or just one party supporting
you no we need a bipartisan solution
this is this immigration especially what
happens to these these women and
children along this border has nothing
to do with politics I mean if we lined
all these kids up in the room I'm sure
you guys would come up with a solution
in a matter of hours and how sad is it
that our colleagues on the other side of
the aisle are not here in McAllen today
in the Rio Grande Valley to see those
unaccompanied minors to to hear the
stories to talk to you and to hear you
saying that you have a recruiting
entertainment problem that we had 17
plus suicides last year it's very sad
um
Colonel McCraw thank you for your
service you know just about an hour ago
I talked to a family member the daughter
of one of the three women who was
missing in Mexico from Benitez right
here in the Rio Grande Valley very sad
situation
um and with with that event with the
recent murders of Americans in Mexico do
you see the cartels acting more brazenly
and in fact let's go a step further do
you see them employing terroristic uh
tactics
they've been employing terrorist tactics
for years this is nothing new
kidnappings of Americans is nothing new
kidnappings extortions uh torture these
things go back decades to the Mexican
cartels so I don't mean to be gratuitous
it's just not covered in Mexico and the
reason it's not I mean being a
journalist is not a good position to be
in in Mexico writing about cartel
violence plain and simple little
targeted I don't care if it's a blogger
or a professional journalist or a judge
or a police officer no one's exempt from
the cartels and their level of brutality
all three of you are law enforcement
professionals military experience if you
see an enemy use a tactic technique or
procedure that threatens the lives of
those that you're in command of or
civilian populations do you disseminate
that information
certainly
so if there it's been alleged that there
was an IED
that was used by the by the cartels
across the border would that be
something that our border patrol agents
would want to know
absolutely I mean I I know as a barber
choice you know I'd like to know
something like that was happening
regardless of where it is on the border
I mean I think it needs to go out to
across all agents all stations that that
be on the lookout for something like
this because it could mean your life
absolutely I assume the same for the
sheriff's department and for DPS
throughout the state of Texas certainly
yeah
um Colonel can you talk to the expense
that the state of Texas has had to
endure because of the abdication
responsibility of the federal government
I'm talking all the expense from the
hospitals to the the jails you know the
operation Lone Star and and stone garden
just in the last couple of years it's
billions of dollars but there's even
more cost because every time we get a
surge like this and where we take
Troopers we take special agents Texas
Rangers and we take resources from other
parts of the state as sheriffs know from
those locations and we send them down to
the borders to be able to do intensified
operations and that takes away a public
safety value in those areas so it
becomes more safe here supporting our
border patrol Partners less safe there
so there's an impact in terms of
Statewide and we recognize that and
certainly the the governor recognizing
that the state legislature has
recognized that but they they may
Governors made it very clear to me is
that at the end of the day is that a a
secured international border with Mexico
is an absolute imperative and without
that we don't have Public Safety in our
homeland security in Texas
I thank you gentlemen thank you for your
testimony in your service with that
chairman of your back gentleman yields I
now recognize the gentlelady from
Georgia Mrs Green
thank you Mr chairman thank
you today and engage
session with us it's a necessary
discussion and again we are outraged and
angered that our Democrat colleagues
didn't see the importance of our
national National Security and our
border security uh even to be important
enough for them to get on an airplane
and come down here and be here for this
hearing shame on them shame on them for
not coming and listening to you and
engaging in this important discussion
about how to protect our country and
protect our border
during Trump's Administration the entire
Administration there were approximately
2 million 437
856 alien encounters in that four years
during the Biden Administration to date
which is just over two years there have
been 4.7 million alien encounters
um just in his time as as president that
is double double it has doubled in just
that short amount of time now under the
Trump Administration there were 581
257 gotaways during four years during
during the abide Administration to date
it is 1.3 million gotaways this is an
incredible increase and it is not by
mistake or accident
in your opinion each of you what are the
policy changes that have happened uh to
to contribute to this invasion of our
country
Mr Cabrera yeah I think uh first you
have the uh the parole we're paroding
people into the United States instead of
uh mandatory detention mandatory removal
um the the talk of uh ending remain in
Mexico and then putting it right back on
a couple days later that had some issues
um before we could set everybody back
and and after Biden restarted it we
could we could only send certain folks
back
um I think those are the two biggest
ones
um if we continue to let people come in
they're going to continue to come in
it's just like with with a kid if you if
you let them do certain things and you
tell them no but there's no there's no
consequence to it they're going to
continue to test those limits and that's
what we're seeing we can tell them all
day long that if you come we'll send you
back but once we release them into the
country they call home they put it on
Facebook or Instagram or whatever they
use
and more people come because regardless
of what I say or or the commissioner or
whoever their their brother their sister
their cousin told them how to do and how
to do it and how it's done and so they
do it open door policies Sheriff Co
well I agree 100 uh because of the lack
of consequences they just continue on
that's why we started Prosecuting for
for a criminal trespass and we've seen
it effective because we're we're pushing
the foot traffic into another County
we're still catching them but not as
many but we're pushing them to another
County I hate to do that but that's the
only way I can protect my County so it
had there has to be consequences that's
right Colonel macroth agreed with Asian
Cabrera
to impeach secretary mayorkas for his
failure as Secretary of Homeland
Security to do his job to protect our
country and in in not doing his job to
enforce policies or bring policies uh
under the Biden Administration that
allow our good men and women of the
Border Patrol and Ice to do their jobs
and I think that's something that should
be done uh definitely but I'd like to
talk to you for a second Mr Cabrera
because you said something that struck
me and I I want to acknowledge this you
you stated in your opening testimony
that you told your wife that you didn't
take this job
for the money because your job you don't
get paid a lot of money border patrol
agents don't get paid a lot of money as
a matter of fact men and women and all
law enforcement don't get paid a lot of
money but you do such an important job
and I thank you for that and you're the
right man for the job so I just wanted
to say that to you but also I I looked
it up uh while we were while the
discussion was going on secretary
mayorkas makes two hundred thousand
dollars a year in his job while he's
failing to do his job and I'm a business
owner and that's what I did all my life
before I became a member of Congress and
I believe in accountability as well and
that's what you gentlemen just spoke of
as accountability and I believe in
accountability to people that are
getting paid to do a job and secretary
mayorkas certainly should not get paid
the big salary that he gets to put men
and women in the border patrol their
lives in danger danger like they are
every single day in our the hearing
before this one uh or actually this
morning it was revealed to us that an
explosive device was found by border
patrol on January 17th
um but it didn't seem to be reported uh
to very high levels and I was just
wondering had you heard about an
explosive device being found in January
absolutely not actually the first I
learned of it was this morning I'm
watching the live stream in the in the
room down the down the hall
right and so that to me that is that's
the cartels taking it to a whole
different level that puts our border
patrol men and women in extreme danger
and and you mentioned how many suicides
did you say there were among border
patrol agents 17. out of out of eighteen
thousand sixteen thousand nineteen
thousand nineteen thousand five hundred
including uh 19 supervisors and
management out of 19 500 there were 17
suicides and you said there were
side under New York 30 out of 30 some 35
000 uh officers uh four four that that
shows the tremendous difference in
stress
professional toll on Border Patrol
agents with with a much higher suicide
rate and that again is devastating
um is is there what do you see could be
done for border patrol agents to make
their jobs uh easier less frustrating
and for them to be able to to accomplish
what they need to do on a daily basis so
if you could answer as quickly as
possible I appreciate that we just need
to be able to get out there let us do
our jobs The Way We Were trained to do
it enforce the laws as they were written
and let the uh the law supersede the
policy as opposed to the policy
superseding the law thank thank you well
said Bob paratrooper all right uh the
gentlelady yields and I recognize Mr
lalota from New York thank you chairman
uh gentlemen thanks for being here for
what you're doing for our great country
I represent a Suburban District in New
York I'm about a mile or excuse me an
hour or two east of Manhattan on the
Yankee in the crowd and appreciate your
hospitality I think I've traveled the
furthest of any uh member in the
committee here uh this this issue is
important to my constituents it's
important to me because New York is
indeed a border state we are a border
state because of the sanctuary City
policies that come from my state we are
a border state because of President
Biden and secretary mayorkas's failed
leadership and we are a border state
because of the lack of infrastructure
technology and Personnel at the border
and my first line of questioning uh is
going to go to the folks from the state
and local the director and the sheriff
you folks are stepping up uh and are
leading where the federal government is
not this is a should be a federal issue
the federal government has a
responsibility to secure our border in
absence of that I commend you and I
thank you on behalf of my constituents
for stepping up we've had tons of
fentanyl deaths in our County about 400
recently we have crime we have overcrowd
in our schools we have legitimate people
looking to go through the immigration
process and folks have cut that line but
your leadership gentleman has uh has
helped thwart some of that so my
question is as a follow-on to Mr
fluger's question what is the cost of
you stepping up in the federal
government's absence in terms of dollars
what have you had to spend first you
director and then Sheriff afterwards
what have you had to spend
to fill those leadership shoes well just
the last two years the state's been over
four billion dollars and they're looking
at spending another 4 billion in the
next biennium and they're having to find
Revenue to be able to do that so they're
not planning on it being the problem
immediately going away and dissipating
and frankly if we would love to see and
by the way 20 three thousand and we're
talking about border patrol agents
you're down to nineteen thousand and
then you talk about New York City One
Police Department's got more officers in
the entire U.S border Patrol and they've
got two boards I mean it's pitiful in
terms of the under investment that The
Thundermans made in Border Patrol over
the years and Border defenses that's my
one comment I'll keep the other my other
comments to myself and many of my
constituents don't know this my
understanding is of Texas 200 and
something counties many of the counties
deploy their officers their deputies to
the border to help secure the borders
254 and they certainly would but they're
usually back at home trying to take care
of the gaps that we leave when we left
and then we send Troopers down south but
there's not a one that that doesn't have
to deal with border related problems in
their jurisdiction already
sheriff on the cost in terms of dollars
to your agency sir on my cost
my current budget's just a little over a
million dollars that's to cover
everything
we're six months into it and I've
already expended all my fuel money so
we've got to borrow from somebody else
we take it from another department
because of issues like that the cost of
EMS having to transport people to and
from at a local hospital which we don't
have we got to go 40 miles to go to a
hospital
about 20 of what we're transporting to
hospitals is a result of immigration
aliens that have succumbed to the Heat
or have some type of broken leg broken
an arm being snaked bit out in the brush
we have to transport them we don't get
reimbursed
so our EMS crew and my office are going
to be in the red again this year because
of this safe to say sheriff and director
you you should you would agree that the
federal government should reimburse you
for those costs they should have been
reimbursing us a long time ago yeah
because the federal government won't pay
for our transport to and from I'm not
sure that Stafford act covers policy
disasters but clearly it is a disaster
and certainly a crisis I agree with that
moving on to opportunity cost huh you're
diverting Resources Personnel equipment
and otherwise to cover the federal
government's back where the federal
government has veiled has failed how
would you address where you're having to
miss the ball back at home in terms of
crimes against people crimes against
property what are you missing because
you have to divert your resources to a
federal government problem
on the county level part of my job is
yes to help get cats out of the trees
hang out with the kids at school teach
the kids to respect law enforcement be
an example
but because of this illegal immigration
my resources are going elsewhere yes we
still handle some of the domestic stuff
the big stuff but being in the public
eye partly were supposed to be
we're out doing border Patrol's job no
offensive border patrol because they're
being tied up doing other things uh my
crew has I've got six full-time deputies
and we spend the majority of our day
processing Smugglers and and illegal
immigrants because the border patrol
can't
so we're missing out on a lot when
things we should be doing that we can't
we have to we have to conduct surge
operations sustain deployments around
the state from resources elsewhere in
the state and continue to move wave and
after wave after wave to be able to
intensely keep intensified out Patrol
operations you know on the river
certainly in the air and on the ground
and the brush streams
let me close by once again saying thank
you you know it's a sacrifice that you
and your officers and deputies are
making personally financially and Us New
Yorkers we do appreciate it I yield Mr
chairman gentlemen yields I now
recognize Mr Luttrell from Texas
thank you Mr chairman good to see
everybody again Colonel and sheriff kill
it's been a while it's good to lay eyes
on you again yesterday we had the
opportunity with DPS to travel around
the on the on the on the river and we
saw where the cartels and on the other
side it was beautiful beautiful homes
just extravagant but cartel have come in
and taken all that over and run away all
the industry and businesses and families
that were there so now it's nothing like
it used to be my question is Sheriff
with the the push across the border into
into your county and surrounding
counties uh how what is the how many
people are leaving what because you said
industry the the sheep in the goat
industry depleted it's gone yes sir are
you seeing that surge more and more and
is it lateral across the borders well
from our side
if we go by the last census uh the
current census shows we have a
population of 3 100 people almost 3 200.
the census before we had 3 900 people
so by that we've lost 700 people in the
past 10 years
but what we're starting to see because
of this is PS people are leaving but
they're selling their properties we've
got one really nice piece of property
that I'd like to have but he's tired of
fixing his fences he offers hunts to
Wounded Warriors and he's constantly in
the in the public eye in our County
anyway helping with the 4-H FFA
literally et cetera Etc he's getting
ready to pull out and we won't see him
again so we will lose that part of the
industry that tax base plus his Goodwill
towards our County keeping us afloat and
the only people that are buying big
tracks of land right now are the people
that are subdividing they start
subdividing it they want to divide it
he's got 3 500 Acres somebody wants to
come in and buy that so and subdivide it
into 10 000 or 10 acre plots which will
completely destroy my County because
people are tired they're getting ready
to leave
just to clarify something that you and I
spoke about if a if a if a Rancher's
fence is torn down and their livestock
exit the ranch and get on the freeway or
the highway systems and a vehicle
strikes that animal it's the ranch's
responsibility to pay correct correct
the Rancher is responsible for that
animal getting on the highway and that
happens quite often it has happened
quite often okay Mr Cabrera the um
and this is the hard one this is the
note we can't seem to crack and I
when it comes to morale and health I
mean in big band two and a half hours to
the Walmart that's not going to change
yeah it's just that's just not yeah we
have to figure out another way how can
we help
enhance the the want desire to be coming
to become an agent but serve in these
challenging areas you know I think a big
part of it is going to be pay parity you
know if somebody can leave uh to a
different organization and get closer to
home I mean it's just common sense that
you know they're they're going to go
home and what the old saying is a happy
wife happy life you know
um and some guys will some guys will
take the commute some guys drive two
hours from El Paso but it it starts to
become a drain on them little by little
so I know the patrol has done some
things as far as uh making it a hardship
station where you could stay for x
amount of years and you could transfer
to a station of your choice so stuff
like that helps out
this may be a little technical but just
with just the advancements the
technology and the areas that we are
short on
officers would it make more sense if we
surge technology in places that maybe
necessarily people don't want to operate
and have that assist a smaller number in
order to enhance numbers somewhere else
most definitely I mean you look at the
um the aerostats those big blimps you
see I mean those things are wonderful
they work wonders for us out here and I
know most of the patrol has lost access
to those we still have them in in the
McAllen areas and and once we lose them
and we will um it's gonna it's gonna be
a big blow to our agents because they're
they're very useful they can operate
Around the Clock they're not worried
about fuel like the helicopters if you
could get those in other places that
that would that would greatly help
I think we might work on that I yield
back sir
the gentleman yields I now recognize Mr
strong from Alabama thank you Sheriff Co
you mentioned that the population of
Kinney Texas is declining I already got
that question answered uh what is the
capacity of your jail and Kenny right
now my jail is closed down because it's
old and it doesn't need gel standards
okay uh how many schools do you have in
Kenny Texas one you have one school do
you have illegal uh aliens being tall in
your school
at this time no thank you uh and I also
want to thank you for going the extra
mile and rather than just kick the can
down the road taking those illegals back
to the border and send them back where
they came from that right there is very
commendable Colonel McGraw uh do you
believe it's time uh that the U.S
military
stops this invasion of the Southern
boredom yeah I certainly believe it's
time for the federal government to do
itself and responsibility and whatever
resources it needs to do it
thank you are you back
the gentleman yields I now recognize the
gentleman from Oklahoma Mr burkine
thank you Mr chairman Sheriff
you had mentioned something this would
not be something that's part of the
record of this hearing about a chance to
introduce myself to you I like your five
inch brim on your good leather work on
your belt and we had a conversation
before this hearing started where you
had mentioned to me in
2005 Circa that there was a policy that
you paid attention to detention
consequences I'd like you to elaborate
on what you shared with me in private to
this committee okay
back in 2005 I was with U.S border
Patrol we started a program that was
called operation streamline
we started in one little part of Del Rio
sector and expanded it as it went on but
every illegal alien caught everybody
male or female was prosecuted for a USC
1325 which is a legal entry into the
United States
it worked we had areas in Eagle Pass
Texas that were seeing groups you know
on apprehension on a daily basis
anywhere between 50 and 150. once we
started that prosecution they went
someplace else once they moved we moved
with them and after about a year year
and a half our apprehensions went
through the floor where we were
apprehending 150 200 a day in
brackaville it went down to 10 or 12 a
day and those are usually they're being
transported in smoking cases but they
too
were prosecuted for illegal entry
and then we expanded that into uh
expedited removal
in other words right there on the spot
we did the paperwork they were moved
back to Mexico and it was considered a
deportation so if they ever entered
again they were facing felony charges
that program worked
and can you elaborate on there was jail
time involved in this correct it's a
deterrent up to 180 days in jail for the
illegal entry which is misdemeanor and
if they were caught again for re-entry
after Deport I believe it's two years or
five years five years they faced after
five years for real re-entry after
Deport
that's great
um what do you experience now can you
elaborate on if you show up on the scene
and uh your your county is not the first
to apprehend them if the border patrol
is there what happens in terms of your
ability to start trespass proceedings
against this person
if we show up on saying and the
landowner wants the ones that are caught
on his property processed and prosecuted
for Criminal Trespass but border patrol
got their hands on them first they will
not give them back to us it's not
because the agents in the field don't
want to it's not because the patrol
agent charge doesn't want to it's coming
from Washington
and and there's so many years of
experience here in front of us at this
table of dealing with this President
Biden has made the comment not one more
foot in regards to you know the building
a fence or wall
director what can you tell me we we saw
I think it was either under DPS or
National Guard in the El Paso sector
rent a fence that the Texas Department
um well there's a was actually where
federal government had stopped the
construction
I took a picture with it it says rent a
fence can you talk to me about Texas's
position on physical barriers
they're an absolute necessor of
necessity and is Congressman Latrell
indicated sometimes you don't need it
Big Ben's a pretty good infrastructure
itself if you've got technology employed
but clearly El Paso when you saw when
you have Venezuelan swelling and along
the the Del Norte bridge in trying to
push in if you don't have the
infrastructure and certainly on some of
the areas where where Texas Military
Department has put concertina wire
another infrastructure then you're going
to get people able to move in such in
such quantities that you can't stop it
so infrastructure plays a key role and I
think that whether it's permanent
infrastructure or even temporary
infrastructure where we had to use
simply because we don't have time to
build the type of fence that needs to be
there it's important
and uh Mr Carrera you represent 16 000
border patrol agents out of almost 20
000 and what is the what is the the guys
and gals that you work with what's their
position on physical barriers we have
people across the nation post 86 amnesty
who would you know who would talk about
that there's no value in physical
barriers what's what are the people that
you work with and your years of
experience what does it tell you on the
value of physical barriers to solve this
problem they work I mean it works 100
percent you know you you may come over
that wall if you climb over that wall
the chances are that our agents are
going to be there to meet you on the
other side it in in Hidalgo if there was
no wall there from the time you left the
river to the time you disappear into the
community is less than 30 seconds but
with that wall up that gives us a good
three four five minutes for you to get
over and get down and our agents are
there so without that wall it doesn't
stop everything but it gives us enough
time to get in position and I mean
there's one around the White House and
there's a reason that it's there because
it works so in terms of allocation of
resources you believe that one agent has
the ability with the fence a fencing
structure has the ability then to be
able to cover much more ground whether
the horseback ATV that that gives that
agent a greater distance and more
efficiency in their day-to-day work yeah
it is a force multiplier it does slow
them down so that our agents can get
there and and get the job done so it is
it's not the only tool in the toolbox
but it is a very necessary tool thank
you I yield
the gentleman he owns uh it would appear
that I skipped one of our members uh my
apologies my deepest apologies to the
gentlelady from Florida you are now
recognized Miss Lee
thank you Mr chairman
today's testimony makes clear that
Mexican drug cartels are trafficking
narcotics weapons and children across
our Southern border and that border
security is collapsing under the failed
policies of the Biden Administration we
must recognize that the Biden
administration's Reckless failure to
secure our border is allowing criminals
to enter our country and undermining the
rule of law between October 2022 and
January 2023 Customs and Border Patrol
officials arrested
9445 individuals with criminal
convictions 209 members of known
criminal organizations and 53 people
whose names appear on the FBI's Terror
watch list what's even more concerning
are the estimated godaways who we cannot
track
one argument that has been made by the
administration in support of their
failed policies is that our Approach at
the southern border should be
humanitarian focused so I would like to
return to a subject of some prior
statements Colonel McCraw that you made
and discuss the humanitarian effects on
people that are coming across this
border those who are exploited injured
or even killed and I would like for you
to share with us if you would your
impression of whether these policies of
the administration are in fact having a
humanitarian effect
well it may seem compassionate but
anytime you attract millions of people
from around the world to essentially
turn themselves over to the Mexican
cartels and we've described in detail in
terms of how violent ruthless they are
you're basically set them up to be
victims of crime and it happens again
and again and again and not just when
they get you know before the river but
on the river but in the other side of
the river and the sheriff code talked
about in terms of abandonments and
you'll see even kids because kids are
great that you can bring with them the
younger the better to bring a kid in
your family unit if you're captured in
that regard but at the same point they
abandoned those kids you know how many
people lives we've lost them so I don't
know Kenny County but certainly Brooks
County right by the the falfurious
checkpoint all of these things are
playing out the investigations we
conduct investigations are very
important when we target the cartels
very important to do but sex trafficking
investigations we've talked about these
major cases you know what what these
cartels and these organizations do is is
to the people is is Indescribable you
don't hear about it it's not reported
much but it's happening and you see it
in our investigations and you certainly
you see it in Patrol operations
tell us if you would what are the
primary types of those investigations
that you see the common things that are
happening criminal conduct that's
occurring that's victimizing these
individuals who are attempting to cross
the southern border illegally
well first enforcement it's very
difficult to tell the difference between
smuggling and trafficking anymore with
the cartels so first and foremost the
money on the front side you can argue
well that's just the smuggling fee but
when they get across they're maintained
and housed and and inside stash houses
and they insist upon calling relatives
to get more money so it's kidnapping in
effect then you get them when they
finally go to their final destination
they know where they're at they know how
to get in contact with them in that
regard and now it's extortion they'll
continue to pay money back to the
cartels that they owe because they
couldn't afford to pay all of it and you
know going back to the policy side of it
is it is that you know people you know
will give up and they've demonstrated
again they will sell everything they
have to be able to try to come to the
United States because it's that
important if they believe they have an
opportunity they won't if they believe
that there are consequences
Asian Cabrera I'd like to ask a similar
question of you one thing that you
mentioned earlier was your belief that
if the children who you had seen
victimized as part of this flood of
individuals illegally across our
Southern border uh were here that we
would reach a policy solution uh tell me
if you would what it is you have
observed with women and children and how
they are being treated coming across our
Southern border just the other day about
probably about a week or so ago maybe
two weeks it was about 35 degrees 40
degrees somewhere in there and we had a
little boy that was brought up by
another group that found him crying on
the river he was four years old he had
one shoe on he was soaking wet and his
parents were already here in the United
States we see that all the time we see
little girls five six seven years old
that their parents are already here and
they sent them in care of a Smuggler and
the parents are in Houston or in Detroit
or or wherever a while back I had a 13
year old girl that came up to us to turn
herself in at the wall in a group of
about 70. we asked for her documentation
and she handed us her birth certificate
she didn't say a word all she did was
cry for the hour and a half it took for
the buses to get out there to come pick
her up she was she we couldn't console
her and I mean God only knows what
happened to that to that young lady I
saw a a lady I think in her late 50s and
she was just pummeled to a bloody pulp
this is about a year ago and the reason
she was pummeled is uh the these uh
River guides tried to get to her 12 year
old granddaughter and she luckily she
fought him off but she paid the price
for it but we see that time and time and
time again and if you did mandatory
detention mandatory removal we wouldn't
see this because we wouldn't be
incentivizing people coming over and and
let's do everything we can let's risk
Our Lives let's risk our young children
let's put our our young girls on on
birth control at the age of 12 or give
them Plan B because as we know that's
part of the journey if we disincentivize
this journey people would stop bringing
taking that Journey thank you Adrian
Cabrera Mr chairman I yield back
the gentlelady yields and uh
I now recognize from her own District
the gentlelady from Texas uh Miss Stella
de la Cruz
thank you so much Mr chairman and um
thank you all for being here today when
I spoke last session I talked about the
importance of technology and
specifically drones and where we had
over 35
detections and 10 000 incursions well
drones that can't work themselves right
we need the man power the agents to be
able to work them so retention and a
recruitment is an important part of
securing the future of our nation so uh
this question actually goes to Mr
Cabrera Mr Cabrera over the last year
due to the failed buy-in policy and the
stress that it has put on our border
patrol agents have you seen an increase
in agent retirement
yeah most definitely and you know like
like we said before technology is great
we can have all the technology in the
world but if we don't have the age bless
you we don't have all the agents on the
ground to stop it
um we're not going to be able to do
anything it used to be when I first came
in and even up until about five years
ago when you hit that retirement age you
had maybe a seven to ten year Gap where
you could go but most guys didn't go
they stayed till mandatory now when guys
hit that retirement age they jump as
soon as they can and that's a shame
because we're losing very senior uh
seasoned agents um that we're just
letting them go do you see that Trend
continuing I see that Trend continuing
and I and I foresee it getting worse
share with the committee here about
Recruitment and recruitment being the
key part of being able to
make sure that whoever's retiring that
not only do we still fill those spots
but even increase our agents at the
border so share with the committee about
polygraph graphs and how polygraphs have
affected recruitment
um you know I think polygraphs have
their place uh I think the border patrol
polygraph I think it's a flawed system
um I know we've had guys that come out
of the military with a security
clearance top secret and they fail the
border patrol polygraph and so they get
sent on down the road I I have tons of
stories whether it's people I know or
people that I'm related to that can't
pass the border patrol polygraph but
they pass the one for Customs or they go
into DPS or they fail at the first time
and pass it the second time
um it's it's just astonishing that
nobody can pass this polygraph and it's
I mean they ask some just ridiculous
questions they even go with it sometimes
I've even heard of them going to
people's sexual orientation on these
polygraphs what that has to do with
anything is is is insane but you know if
there is a place for it they need to
revamp that system and make it so that
we're not losing good candidates to DPS
which which we are and you know it's
it's good for them it's bad for us so is
this something that the polygraph test
and how it's being utilized with the
border patrol recruitment something you
would like this committee to take a look
at most definitely I mean like we said
before we're losing tons of great agents
uh for just silly silly technology
tell us about overtime overtime caps and
how that affects maximizing the boots on
the ground and we have overtime caps I
can't I don't know the exact numbers on
it but we do have a cap on overtime so
if we work it early on in the year uh
which the like this time of the year
everybody starts taking their overtime
and then towards uh September October
November there's
you know no overtime left because even
if it's available the agents can't go
over that cap to work it because they've
made too much already so let me make an
example for my colleagues here that I
think is very important so people are
maximizing their overtime right now so
let's just say November if we had a
migrant flow of 10 000 Haitians come
over like they did in the past years
people would be maxed out on their
overtime and could not go out and assist
is that correct that is correct thank
you very much and I yield back
the gentleated yields and I just want to
add that in the Border
bill that we have put together the
polygraph issue is addressed so
hopefully the administration will sign
that bill and the Senate will pass it
but uh for law enforce prior law
enforcement and Military
etc those are the security clearance the
polygraph will be waived
a couple of admin notes uh first for the
committee members we have some food for
you in the round table room and we will
do the press conference in about 20 to
30 minutes Mr chairman could I ask you I
know that every member was notified of
the gentleman is recognized thank you Mr
chairman thank you I know that every
member was notified about this Committee
hearing could you tell me what date we
were notified so that we could make our
schedules available for this most
important Hearing in Texas
actually the Press give me just a second
I got to find the exact date for you
it was at least a week ago I want to
give you the actual date
um February 21st was actually the the
first notice thank you yep
um I think the panel of the witnesses
for being here incredibly valuable
testimony the members of the committee
may have some additional questions for
you and they'll submit those in writing
you can submit your answers in writing
persuant to the committee rule 7D the
hearing record will be held open for 10
days for such testimony without
objection the committee stands adjourned